hello today I wanted to make a
horrible video corresponding to in the taxi
so make an Italian the title is
100 native speakers in
foreign language learning and therefore I would like
to tell you for a moment about what
I do in general for my perspective on
this aspect of  language learning
first of all I would like to say that
phonics apart from some experts is still
a very interesting and little
explored field in reality by let's say in
quotes by the live mesh
manners community as they call them in English but it
is a vast topic and in reality it is not
much  explored apart from some
famous books on phonetics now the
generally pragmatic problem that we all
face is to ask ourselves if
to ask ourselves a series of questions for
example all more or less all
hope, apart from some exceptions, to
speak a foreign language with a
accent not only decent but also and
possibly also as a native speaker
in short so so co  so perfect that it
is mistaken for a local
now the questions to ask are is an
effort that is worth doing and it is
possible for anyone so it is an
accessible capacity but a way of a
capacity in short accessible to anyone
and we should be satisfied  simply
with a continuous clear pronunciation and
therefore of an intelligibility there is
an understanding that is simply to
make ourselves understood well and therefore aspire to
speak well from the grammatical point of view
semantic syntactic
etc. etc.
now the problems these are the questions to
ask general problems of
in learning an accent
in the acquisition of an accent there are
various i.e. what are the barriers
first of all there are a series of
psychological barriers that are
especially part of the adult world for example
all of us indiscriminately when
we speak another language we feel
less secure because  we don't speak it
well because we don't know a lot of
things yet then  one of the biggest fears and
those of appearing clumsy and for
example very often of managing a
conversation with many pauses with
stammering it is therefore in general
apart from these are the main psychological problems
faces a speech that is
not able to express itself however  there
is not only the
psychological factor but also the physical factor in the
sense that speaking a language with an
accent means above all knowing
how to coordinate on the ear,
that is to say to listen but also to coordinate the
brain with the mouth and when I speak of the
mouth I mean mouth tongue nose  glottis
in the sense that a foreign language is
a language in general including Italian
is pronounced and produced with
everything we have
the problem is that
it is a real
physical exercise that is, it is a question of using the muscles
to put them in motion  therefore of a
training a training that can be done
in the sense that very often it is a training
that lacks comp  I don't want to talk about everyone in the baggage of,
for example, the learning of
languages by teachers but v
ry often the p
onetic aspect is an aspect that there are those
who say it comes by itself in the sense that one l
arns the language and then begin
to  speak it although it is not necessarily
true apart from these two these
two barriers that is, there is the
psychological factor and the real physical
one speaking of pronunciation we say
that one of the most important things
in our favor is the fact that the number
of sounds used by  a language for
each specific language and relatively
limited in the sense that there are also
other videos about it on the internet he
likes lilac the international phonetic alphabet
foresees perhaps more than 250
sounds of Italian for example he uses 50
so in reality it is to understand the mechanics
of single words and therefore of sounds
is not an impossible thing because it is
limited the problem is that you have to
understand the intonation of an entire sentence
here  ndi resuming the speech of the
single sounds there are three main categories
which are the sounds that already exist in
our language there are the sounds that are
similar but not equal to those of
our language that there are
completely different sounds that is completely
new that there are aliens  in quotation marks
now regarding the sounds that
are similar and there is no problem
once one is said in the thick
in the introduction of languages we are told this
a is the same as the Italian one we breat
e a sigh of relief ok th
s l  'we have saved it
we have understood it the problem
concerns the naturally alien sounds
that is completely different but also and
above all the most
in English we use the word jacks that is
a bit of a trap and they are the sounds that
are similar because in this sense they
exist  a phenomenon called sound
mapping in which our brain
maps sounds that are similar in what
our mother tongue sounds are
so for example a t that seems to us to
be the same as our reality is not
we will pronounce it badly unless
someone does
not have it do not let us notice that we understand it
we will continue to pronounce it in
Italian I do not speak only of
consonants but  I am also talking about vowels and
pitch
and speaking of pc that is intonation
to understand now passing to the
less evident aspect which is that of
int  in general in a natural way it is
necessary to take into account a whole
series of factors such as
the intonation therefore the fact that some
vowels are particularly high or
particularly long that certain
consonants are pronounced in one way and
another in general
actually the most important part
it concerns more the vowels in this sense
than the consonants but everything contributes to
forming, let's say, a sentence
said well in this sense, that is therefore
p  speaking of prosody I would like to tell you that
for those who know Chinese the
Chinese in ca5 tones 4 tones plus a
neutral tone you can see the video I
put on my blog about it there is a
beautiful girl who exposes the Chinese tones
I do this quote  of tones because
I would like to use Chinese tones to
apply a language that is not tonal
which is Italian
you can also see for a moment
briefly the explanation between
tonal language in non-tonal language but in
general we assume that the first
Chinese tournament a high and continuous tone that  it is for
example therefore the corresponding vowel
would be a and I therefore instead the fourth
tone is a tone that descends a tone that
falls it is said in Italian it corresponds
to the 100 tonic for example the same
word tonic and tonic and instead the
fifth tone that the bull is not  author is
represented by the by the vowels
that in Italian are less evident in
this sense if we consider a
three-syllable word in which the tonic accent
falls s  In the second typical example
we will take you will see that it is plan of a m
so a first tone a fourth bull is a
neutral tone because the final part
remains at the bottom between mini quotes is
less evident therefore and let's
consider this word to tell you that
this means this word  in this
word both the mechanics of the language in the
sense that it is understood that for this reason it
is already a is a combination of
consonants then it is a long vowel which
then takes you cascadia and then you are
low in quotation marks so we take
everything in this word c  'is the mechanics
of the language but the dynamics of the language
means that this 6
in verb inserted in a context in a sentence
if we are with friends for example
we want to go on the highway let's say let's
take the highway in this case
but we take them of these  of this
sentence is different at the level
of vowel shift, i.e. the level of
vowels and how they are pronounced
compared to the single one, in fact, let's not
say  or more we take but we take
the highway because in
this sentence in this sentence the accent of the sentence falls on
highway ends is the important one
since the Italian aggregates groups of
blocks of words and considers them
one word
in this case therefore everything  what
precedes highway all that
precedes so let's take it is all at the top
at the level of vowels that I
call it all at the top is a bit of
a rather trivial way to call it that
but they are all high tones
this to make it clear that the  difference
that one could for example learn
perfectly to pronounce every word
and every focal word every consonant
but this is not the same as saying that then
in practice he can speak a
language in the way that the
native speaker handguards because there are quite a
series of  phenomena that are part
of the intonation of the prosody of the
time etc. etc.
tto
be able to frame the vowels in a way
let's say the sounds separately
because they are limited there is the problem
of intonation but the advantages of
speaking as a raw material are many
socially for example I very
often happened to start
speaking  with strangers maybe I
said something in English to them less
this knows you speak English well how do
you speak like this so it is
an icebreaker for example but not only
to meet foreign people or
strangers but in other contexts in
terms of communication in a
native language for  a message said with
an accent almost in quotation marks from a mother
tongue mother tongue is very clear, always
bearing in mind,
even in terms of expressive quality, with respect to one instead
that it is a very heavy accent and then
also a pleasant thing, in short, then
also culturally and linguistically
the person who  ti and front does not
need to adjust its registo
its tone to lower in t
high-level quotes and above all
psychologically it is said very often
this is something that some of you have
surely noticed that if you speak
bergi usually speaking a language and
a barrier badly but if you spoke a
foreign language yes if you feel
even more  loose with respect to
one's mother tongue is a phenomenon that
has happened to me many times and is a
booster that is a huge advantage in
terms of the communication work of
various friendship financing so
let's say it is worth trying to speak
like a native speaker or at least of  try
and get to an excellent level and
in my opinion it is something that we can
all do with targeted work and some
help so this is the message of the
video thank you very much and see you in the
second part where I will explain in more
detail what I do good  day